s'habiller pour résister au froid pierre
leroy a fait le choix d'une triple
épaisseur ce vendeur de fruits et
légumes pense aussi à la protection de
ses produits tout ce qu'il veut être
principalement salade d'endives les
produits plus fragiles parce qu'ils sont
gorgés d'eau et puis après d'autres
produits vont résister très bien - 2 - 3
mais après il faut sortir les produits
au dernier moment pour pas qu'ils
prennent un coup de froid sur ce marché
la fréquentation est en baisse durant
l'hiver mais des habitués bravent le
froid pour faire leurs courses
je m'habille très chaud avec casquette
les pvc et est double chasse est je
viens régulièrement tous les mercredis
tous les samedis je me couvre plus
chaudement effectivement c'est tout
après les fêtes de fin d'année les
ventes sont relativement calme au niveau
des poissons et des fruits mer en cause
l'arrêt des pêches pour dans une semaine
après le nouvel an pour les marchandises
proposées la conservation des produits
et adaptées aux températures hivernales
la petite technique en hiver pour
utiliser moins de glace on rajoute tout
simplement un ou deux couvercles en
polystyrène en plus pour éviter
d'utiliser trop de glace alors qu'on
était en en mai le strict minimum pour
pouvoir remplir le bac quasiment
entièrement glace pour l'habillement non
plus de couches pas forcément mais vos
meilleures qualités des baisers
vêtements beaucoup plus chaud parce
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de vent et les
températures sont inférieures à zéro ça
pique un petit peu capuche bonnets
écharpes et tricot sont de sortie et
pour les plus courageux il n'y a pas de
secret rester en mouvement est le
meilleur moyen pour conserver sa chaleur
corporelle